il ya première chose évidente c'est sa
banque leur relation qu'on peut
entretenir avec sa banque on s'aperçoit
que année après année vous avez des
frais bancaires qui augmente l'âge et
regarder les chiffres c'est hallucinant
ce qu'on appelle le lait frais de
retrait déplacé par exemple ils ont pris
40% de plus c'est quoi les frais de
retrait déplacé c'est quand vous allez
au distributeur de billets dans une
autre banque que la vôtre na waie alors
avant vous aviez droit à 4 à peu près
trois quatre retraits gratuits par mois
et puis après c'était facturé 1 euro
cela les banques globalement on baisser
ce nombre de retraits gratuit à 2 à peu
près donc dès que vous dépassez de
retrait dans un autres distributeurs que
chez vous vous payer un euro ça c'est
intéressant de faire attention et c'est
intéressant ça et ça on n'y pense jamais
donc est-ce qu'il faut négocier avant
martial avec sa banque dire attendez moi
je peux je vais négocier en devenir
c'est plus une discipline personnelle
cessé de le savoir une fois qu'on sait
de faire attention parce que en général
vous savez comment ça se passe à l'est
les agents se sont toutes les unes dans
la mer elle n'est rien à côté des autres
dans la même rue non bon plutôt que de
payer un euro pour soirée allons faire
ça sans mettre de plus à s'éveiller dans
sa propre cage le savez maintenant
proprio pas bon il fallait pas vous avez
vous avez aussi un truc à savoir parce
que elle communique beaucoup mais les
banques en ligne sont énormément moins
cher 10 fois moins cher en termes de
frère donc c'est vrai les autres on voit
sur les banques en ligne ça c'est vrai
oui ça c'est vrai parce que aujourd'hui
vous avez l'ensemble du secteur bancaire
qui vous pousse de toute façon aller
vers le service en ligne je donne un
exemple tout bête lorsque vous allez
dans votre agence et vous demander de
faire un virement beaucoup de gens font
ça ils vont au guichet et voila
j'aimerais envoyer 250 euros à ma mère
vous allez payer 3 euros mais si vous le
faites sur internet avec votre
application c'est gratuit donc et femmes
même pour n'importe quelle banque pas
forcément une banque uniquement en ligne
donc c'est des petits trucs à savoir
pourrait vous éviter tout cette approche
est ce que vous êtes proche de votre
banquier est ce que vous pourriez faire
un tulle est venu conclure votre banque
et
franchement respect pourriez le faire
non vraiment pas vous oui bien sûr ah
oui il est vraiment très liées à la gare
mais c'est vrai pour
sa patience dabany
on est devenus amis un an dès 2012
mais vous avez vérifié vos frais
bancaires comme l'a dit martial ouais
non non mais c'est j'en ai beaucoup trop
malheureusement après c'est vrai mais je
crois que ça va me c'est surtout qu'il a
trouvé un pigeon il faut se méfier des
promotions oui il faut se méfier des
promotions en tous cas se méfier de ce
qui paraît moins cher par exemple en ce
moment il ya une sorte de scandale c'est
ce qu'on appelle sais pas si vous
connaissez les mdd dans les grandes
surfaces c'est même pas des promos
d'accord les mdd marques de
distributeurs
dans une grande surface et vous vous
regardez les prix et vous dit à bas la
marque carrefour aux gens ce qui
m'importe moi là elle est moins chère
effectivement que le même produit d'une
marque nationale connus et ça sauf que
quand vous regardez l'évolution des prix
depuis un an ses marques là elles ont
progressé de 7% alors que les autres
marques ont progressé de 2 3% maxxo que
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont
baissé les prix au départ pour raciale
voilà pour nous chauffer et puis
maintenant et on le voit pas mais on se
dit on regarde pas le prix c'est que les
gens - vous avez pouvoir d'achat plus
vous achetez ces produits là parce
qu'ils sont au départ moins cher c'est
ça vous avez plus de 50% de leymarie
sont peut-être moins cher
comment peut être maintenant ils sont
plus ou moins cher ne sais pas il ya
toujours un écart mais simplement pour
celui qui ne se nourrit que avec des
marques de distributeurs lui il a pris 7
% de plus sur son sur son caddie à la
fin de l'année c'est des choses que
auquel vous faut faire particulièrement
attention que les intérêts non
j'adorerais il faut comparer les prix
des fournisseurs d'énergie ça c'est
important alors c'est qui les
fournisseurs d'énergie
vous avez vous avez ce qu'on appelle les
distributeurs historiques dont vous pour
le gaz cnj pour les positionner bien sûr
et puis après vous avez depuis quelques
années ce qu'on appelle les opérateurs
alternatifs maintenant vous avez total
nrj vous avez émis vous avez tout
iberdrola tout un tas d'acteurs qui sont
soit français soient étrangers qui se
sont mis sur le marché simplement là il
faut les oublier si je veux donner un
conseil vous n'allez vous n'allez plus
sur ces
versets fourni sur la mêmes ont tendance
à vous laisser repartir gentiment parce
que les prix du gaz et l'électricité ont
progressé de 50% à peu près minimum
depuis un an et ils ne sont plus
capables ces fournisseurs alternatifs de
vous garantir des prix moins cher que
les tarifs dits réguliers et hervé c'est
le tarif bleu d'edf donc pour l'instant
en tout cas ni vaut mieux privilégier et
les acteurs historiques cela le prix est
encadrée et donc ils peuvent pas le
faire exploser c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement a dit on va pas au-delà de
4% d'augmentation de la facture
d'électricité c'est sur les tarifs
régulés c'est pas pour les autres tarifs
astuce économie les 10 conseils pour
éviter d'être à découvert tous les mois
on est que martial you qui nous donnent
des conseils nous en a déjà quatre qui
sont extrêmement intéressants et
franchement les 4 j avais pas pensé je
vous dis vraiment je n'ai pas pensé
aucun 5 vous dites pour pour faire des
économies tout les mois qu'il faut
utiliser des sites d'achats de
l'occasion alors expliqué alors les
sites d'achats d'occasions c'est le plus
connu c'est vintage et d'ailleurs il est
troisième site de e-commerce en france
maintenant donc ça a énormément paris
nice est osé et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a vu arriver depuis la crise et
depuis la pandémie c'est à dire que il
ya eu une explosion évidemment du
commerce en ligne mais aussi de tous les
achats d'occasion c'est pourquoi c'est
intéressant parce que d'une part lorsque
vous achetez quelque chose d'occasion
vous allez avoir 30% à peu près de prix
en dessous par rapport au même produit 9
mai mais surtout vous allez pouvoir
acheter des produits de meilleure
qualité c'est un peu ce qui existe dans
la dans l'automobile c'est que si vous
avez sur une dacia d'occasion j'adore
les dacia cci voiture attendait
patiemment son regard mais évidemment à
l'occasion occasion sur le marché
d'occasion c'est moins rentable que si
vous avez une grosse allemande mais bien
sûr donc alors moi j'ai vu
personnellement dans la maison où s'est
pas de voiture
et au regard
des fuites non j'ai sorti deux ans avec
angela merkel mais bien sûr n'ont pipé
mot non mais c'est vrai donc voilà il
faut utiliser des sites d'achats
d'occasions voilà le consommer local et
saisonniers qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça ça c'est la suite de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure les nouvelles habitudes
qu'on a prises pendant la crise c'est à
dire faire marcher sont son fournisseur
de viande locale le paysan du coin faire
marcher le petit commerce d'à côté et
surtout acheter en vrac c'est à dire que
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir se
détacher de ce qui est déjà en pacte et
et est fourni en 250 500 grammes ou un
kilo pourquoi parce que dans les mois
qui viennent tous ces produits qui sont
empaquetés vont prendre énormément de
hausses de prix pour cora parce que le
papier parce que le vert à voir ce que
le carton tout ça a énormément le
plasticien a énormément augmenté donc si
vous achetez en vrac d'abord vous prenez
que ce dont vous avez véritablement
besoin si vous avez besoin de 100
grammes vous prenez pas un paquet de
sens que si on veut prendre de l'argent
s'il faut qu'on achète beaucoup de
cartons qu'on les revendre dans
l'alaska potard des biens et services a
rien d'affolant des kuchis avec et dans
les matches ah oui parce que le mec qui
était dans les matches à l'époque on se
disait franchement bon c'est pas ouf tu
voi le mec qui était dans les mares ce
qui ne vous rendez pas parce que moi je
dis souvent il y aura des milliardaires
du comider mais franchement sur cet été
on va être tranquillement à saint tropez
train de passer sur le port et vous
allez voir des bateaux de 60 mètres non
ça c'est le gars qui a fait les masques
ça c'est qui s'abattent à ses valeurs et
à côté de m modern art
aujourd'hui dharma siens laveuses et moi
l'année prochaine dans le classement des
500 fortunes france d'avoir masqué des
mecs de l'avocat des pharmaciens et que
des mecs qui monte des masques et non
médecins mais aussi de lambda qui ont
acheté des actions par maastricht sur
les iphone tout ça cj c'est vrai qu'il
va avoir des milliardaires du comice a
commencé oui ça commence et on voit bien
d'ailleurs que les sites de e-commerce
que soit amazon que apple aujourd'hui
vos 3 milliards donc avait alors je ne
sais pas sur moi j'avais deux minutes on
va faire la monnaie non mais c'est voilà
c'est tout ce qui est internet a
énormément progressé si en face il y 3
milliards à peine remis du ca pour une
pomme
en plus croquer ok
ok vous trois mais même le mec est même
franchement même le truc de trouver la
pomme croquée le gag vais tranquillement
avec sa meuf comme ça il a croqué à
pompey mais écoute et compense cette
embauche une pomme croquée non mais sans
déconner c'est vrai j'ai pensé à ça
c'est fou comment des fortunes comme ça
ce fonds est ce que vous êtes souvent
découvert
voudrait qu'on a découvert benjamin pas
là mais je peux plus à découvrir ma
d'accord non j'avais des gros découvert
très couvert j'ai dû très gros découvert
les médailles menem sur calais à
l'époque j'habitais attention moi ah
ouais ça fait très attention vous
surtout d'année prochaine gilles
apparaît comme valérie je fais attention
c'est un petit bijou retour à toi tu
dois je suis très dépensier je suis tout
le temps découvert non vraiment pas tout
le temps ah ouais tout le temps que
c'est pour ça que c'est le banquet et
son ami exactement c'est donc cette
matière de langage a vu que non j'ai
vraiment pas une vie de fou ah ouais non
pas tellement j'ai pas de fringues c'est
une belle voiture ce monstre le truc
mais sinon voilà le pape a tellement
vacances et pas que j'avais une belle
voiture sujet une jolie voiture
allemande sujet une grosse amende salée
mais à quoi
alain beaud levier de vitesse mais se
dit mort merci
moi je fais attention je suis dans un
métier où on peut travailler beaucoup et
puis après pendant un moment ne pas
travailler donc ça apprend à faire
attention aux cocons métier
f à doha elle a fait des films
incroyables ouais ouais ouais ouais et
vous vous avez acheté la banque
vous
le lien qui vous voyez vous de banquiers
monde a
trouvé très bien l'appeler lui feras tu
l'as vu
pourquoi moi j'ai tu as découvert avant
que mas pied pour un final matin la
radio ça va les indices précis fort
à l'effort quand vous êtes découvrir
avant goût marqué pour un al-mathaf
herbe la radio j'avais fait une société
de livraison de boissons j'avais perdu
toutes mes économies j'avais perdu
cinquante mille euros d'économie nos se
retrouver à 473 euros de découvert
j'avais appelé mon propriétaire à
l'époque j'avais dit laissez-moi ce
loyer là je ne paye pas je vous le
paierez en fin d'année parce que je vais
emmener mes enfants avec les 1000 bahts
je vais emmener mes enfants en vacances
que c'était 960 euros le loyer à
l'époque c'est très cher et j'avais
emmené mes enfants en vacances à la
plage et a découvert et le mois d'après
m'avait appelé avec laurent thibeault
pour me dire tu vas signer pour faire de
la radio chez nous la fait pas ça fait
plaisir ce que je suis à découvert 470
un fou et loïc qui la connaissent
l'histoire lui damer déroule mais voilà
mon frère et ami loïc joly c'est fou la
vie qu'on lui connaît cette histoire il
doit se dire il nous fait bien chier
les gars
voilà oui moi quand j'étais jeune de
vécu ça comme un traumatisme ah ouais
ouais j'ai connu les huissiers
l'annexion bancaire découvert à wes est
faux et depuis effectivement je fêterai
gaffe c'est traumatisant on doit on aura
trois nouveaux conseils en fait de
nouveaux conseils parce que j'aurai
concours seo 8e débranchée des appareils
est oui alors ça c'est un truc auquel on
pense pas du tout moi je me suis amusé à
avant de venir à faire un petit calcul
sur tout ce qui est branché à la maison
et sans mentir je peux vous faire gagner
100 euros en tout la bri avec toi si si
maintenant c'est vrai c'est en enlevant
les trois géants ou un geste simple 60
euros par consentir au sur 1 aura mais
pas évident mais ça c'est quand même ça
fait dix balles par mois avec son louis
d'abord les ampoules led ça consomme
énormément moins que les ampoules
classiques vous changez vos ampoules de
vous débranchez
l'ensemble de tous les chargeurs de
portables mais que vous laissez même
clairement sur la table au bout mais oui
même quand il est et surtout quand il
n'y a rien au bout il continue à
affronter d'électricité la cafetière qui
est toujours branché ça c'est pareil et
vous rajoutez le la boîte wifi que vous
pouvez ça fera plaisir aux enfants
coupée à partir de minuit par exemple si
vous débranchez le wifi simplement avec
un bouton à l'interrupteur c'est d'abord
je vous promet qu'avec ces trois gestes
là j'avais fait les calculs et ce sont
les quelques jours ci sert des mavericks
vous avez quasiment santoro il ya un
piège à éviter en ce moment parce que
c'est très à la mode est traité de
larbin castel
[Rires]
ça aurait pu dire
non il ya eu ce qu'on appelle les achats
fractionné vous savez si tous et ça ça
marche énormément en ce moment c'est
payant 4 x 100 m ah ouais alors ça les
associations de consommateurs commencent
à tirer la sonnette d'alarmé parce
qu'elles disent attention à pas il a
cumulé en fait le problème c'est pas de
dedans de m'avoir 1 4 fois sans frais
très bien mais là plus vous êtes fragile
financièrement plus vous avez tendance à
les accumuler et c'est ce qu'on appelle
les dépenses contraintes c'est à dire
qu'au bout d'un moment va bien falloir
quand même les régler ces cas échéant
cela quand vous les avez vous les
ajouter les unes derrière les autres
vous vous retrouvez au bout de trois
quatre mois avec une surcharge de ce que
vous devez qui est absolument impossible
quelquefois centre caf faut faire gaffe
on peut le faire sur un voile à aller
lui mulet il n'y a pas de contrôler les
autres les autres prêts crédits sont
contrôlés lasser c'est un peu plus libre
en revanche une question importante est
ce qu'on peut payer les chroniqueurs en
4 x 100 x
c'est surtout sans frais qui vont ainsi
être c'est même trop donc c'est possible
on peut le faire si vous avez des
questions à marcel n'hésitez pas un bien
entendu autre conseil se faire une liste
de courses et s'y tenir bah oui bah oui
vous savez combien de kilos on jette
chacun tous les ans
parce qu'on a parce qu'on a acheté des
produits qu'on a laissé dans le frigo
est plein aux oubliés papa 20 à 30 kg
non à 20 à 30 kg qui partent à la
poubelle de nourriture périmée ou qui
n'ont pas qui n'a pas été suffisamment
bien utilisé donc c'est à l'uci ans à
ces quelques c'est quelque part un
scandale qu'on peut changer les uns et
les autres individuellement c'est donc
là c'est tout simple vous faites votre
course votre liste de courses en
fonction de vos menus de la semaine
lundi soir pour l'ensemble de la famille
est comme ça vous savez exactement de
combien de carottes vous avez besoin de
combien de viande vous avez besoin
d'acheter enfin voila vous équilibrez en
plus à peu près ça vous n'êtes pas dans
l'improvisation parce que lorsqu on
improvise on prend le premier truc qui
vient voir en commande parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de faire la cuisine ce soir et
ça évidemment c'est un surcoût et moi on
s'est vite improvisé mois quand ils
m'ont appris le coup voilà oui madame nm
moi on m'a dit aussi que par exemple
quand on veut acheter un produit pour
différencier les papillotes d'il ya plus
de différentes marques pour le même
produit il faut regarder le prix au kilo
et bien sûr c'est qu'on est là qu on
sait qu'elle est bien sûr pas parce
qu'il ya des astuces il ya des astuces
marketing sur les formats dits familiaux
et ses marques et familiale en grand et
en général quand vous regardez le prix
au kilo vous apercevez qu'il est plus
cher que le lait de même à 250 g de 500
grammes il est plus cher gestionnaire
commentaire sur ses bras il a raison
dans les supermarchés vous regardez
toujours le prix au kilo est un super
fois vous allez avoir un packaging qui
est joli c'est assez joli en a plus plus
de gratuit à marquer des façons de trucs
là et quand vous regardez au culot lota
côté les moins chers il a raison ce
qu'il vient de dire cela mais ça y est
les prises électriques magnifique alors
être
allez c'est fou ce que vous dites est le
conseil numéro un est-ce que ça aide
aussi de découper son budget par exemple
on dit voilà ce mois ci je vais faire
pour 300 euros de courses pourtant
d'électricité de façon à bien s'y
repérer et à s'y tenir pour paver passé
alors oui évidemment si tout le monde a
passé trigger là ça le truc c'est que il
faut quand même le faire de façon
stricte précise alors là dessus les
applications sur ce téléphone peuvent
aider parce que vous voyez au jour le
jour ce qui se passe et c'est utile
aussi pour pouvoir justement savoir leur
reste à vivre à la fin du à la fin du
mois à dire que lorsque vous avez
accumulé vous ça vous le faites une fois
pour toutes combien j'ai de crédit de
remboursement de frais fixes qui tombent
tous les mois et qu'est ce qui me reste
est à partir de là vous pouvez diviser
en vous disant ben voila je vais avoir
100 200 300 euros par par semaine juste
avant le sommet comment vous dépensez
par mois vous dites la vérité voilà à
peu près pas par moi
raymond roger roger oui moi j'essaye
toujours de faire 150 euros les cours
semblent parler d'eux prénommé en tout
ou en tout cas en tout avec le loyer
avec moi voyez j'en serais moi j'ai
entré à crédit à 800 euros après j'ai
des courses ça peut faire 400 euros de
courses par mois
afp des milliers de près de 1000 euros
par mois un plomb - un peu moins un mois
puisque j'arrive avec mon salaire de
deux livreurs moi je sais pas tout il ya
internet fotolia les radis
loyer qu'on partage à deux les courses
avec trois enfants un petit vous faites
des listes ou si vous voyez ce que vous
dépensez vos playlists avec des menus on
veut pas réfléchir à ce qu'on va manger
le soir et donc du coup on fait des
merveilles c'est pas pour faire des
économies bah en fait aussi parce que si
vous faites des menus avec du caviar
c'est sûr
mais c'est vrai que je trouve que c est
vous dites qu'il faut acheter au détail
on a besoin d'aller prendre un juste un
yaourt ou de yahoo
il ya la possibil
la la il ya ça dépend du code-barres il
y en a qui sont vendus en pack vous faut
pas faut pas trop jouer avec ça mais en
théorie au droit de la consommation vous
autorise à prendre de yaourt sur un
paquet de six l'accord lorsque vous
allez arriver à la caisse ça va être un
peu moins agréable le moment oui parce
que sa fougue et genton
j'ai fait tout ça pour
des cons c'est dans ce sens que tu
transpires la vérité oui beaucoup trop
d'argent une fourchette enfin plusieurs
dizaines de milliers
la vérité ou non minarets dans plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros par mois
mais non mais quand la vérité
dix mille euros oui mais tentant
d'entrer de quoi autant d'entrées pour
dépenser autrement oui il est prenable
félicitations et
travaille dans un bar tapas
voilà plus de quinze bien oui oh la la
plus de 20000
oui quoi luttons pas me farmine doivent
arrêter et puisque si rim là vous
dépensez vos lacets alors
sur le poids de chômage des dépenses
pour vous vous faites le bateau c'est
que juillet-août
ils sont pas que le prec sur l'âge de ta
gueule
est-ce que les jets sont moins chers la
salle c'est une vraie question
s'il vous plaît on était sur un avenir
non mais est donc et donc vous êtes donc
c'est tout
castaldi vous vous étiez tout le temps a
découvert il a une anecdote castaldi et
l époque où les banques et il voulait
c'est d'y descendre décembre décembre 17
décembre et moi il m'a vraiment lésés
descendre très très très très bas hasebe
ça sert à ça m'a coûté ça a été tu as
participé à ma chute jusqu'à deux
millions huit
soyez oui il avait 2009 4,2 millions 8,2
millions huit cent mille euros de
droits et vous laisser souk sebt ça
dépend de ce qu'il ya à côté j'ai en
fait il avait pris à l'époque des primes
département garantie ah oui on dit
maintenant faut rembourser mais oui
comme comment je fais on va vous prendre
votre appart à brécey a commencé comme
ça non remboursés oui oui c'était ma
pensée la connerie
de 800000 euros de découvert incroyable
c'est incroyable avec stan lee alain
mais vraiment castaldi c'est un délire
y laissa un délire tout en s'occupant
des indemnités le gars est un délire à
lui apporte quoi non pas dormir à
l'écouté je dormais pas mal à l'époque
mais voit ses rêves d'un million deux
cent mille euros découvert il dormait
trop
ça va y'a pas le feu au lac non mais
sans déconner c'est le soldat il avait
deux cent mille euros de découvert mais
il allait faire du coup c'est l'idole 30
et l'arrivée la carte est pas c'est pas
toi non non ça passe pas dit non mais ça
c'est un truc de fou deux millions et
600 mille euros un essai tout détailler
si vous voulez quoi je me rappelais j'ai
tout détailler
96 euros d'abonnement de téléphone
internet et les matchs de foot et cool
compagnie 450 euros de courses 250 euros
de gasoil 55 euros d'assurance par mois
de la voiture est la preuve des petites
brive et les règles de sucreries
vous avez tout faux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis à 4 et 500 euros
alors on a on a un dernier conseil à
vous donner pro n'aura d'autre à des
astuces des économies pour éviter d'être
à découvert tous les mois je sais que
vous adorez cette séquence n ya
énormément de réactions et tout ce que
vous dites franchement c'est frappé au
coin du bon sens là ça nous change dans
cette émission
vraiment c'est important au gouver
l'eau oui alors est ce qu'il faut faire
il faut alors on le dit souvent il faut
prendre une douche plutôt qu'un bain
mais on le dit souvent pour des raisons
économiques ou écologiques et
technologiques et économiques aussi
puisque vous dépensez quatre fois moins
d'eau quand vous utilisez une douche
quand vous utilisez un bain donc
forcément vous avez à la fin - d'au
moins deux factures pour pour l'eau
aussi je vous passe quand on a une piste
sèche c'est
il me semble que vous avez un petit
pied-à-terre avec une petite piscine ont
alors j'ai une piscine municipale en
face
à plus jamais dos et là même qui n'est
pas à moi non mais il ya des choses
toutes bêtes parfois parce que prenons
le frigo parce que c'est lié à allauch
aussi quelque part lorsque vous avez un
réfrigérateur si vous le délivre est
régulièrement ça vous savez vous allez
faire jusqu'à 30% d'économies qui n'ont
pas cours à 30 % de moins d'électricité
donc ça c'est des choses qu'il faut
prendre en considération parfois c'est
un peu de discipline individuelle la
machine à laver mais vous l'avez à 30°
plutôt qu'à 62 moi je lave souvent trop
de devoirs faits mais machine à eybens
maximin oui oui mais c'est bien en plus
après vingt-trois ans
après vente pour dire que la vaisselle
la machine d'appréciation pourquoi qu'on
leur dise
qu'on
arrive à lui n'en retrouvera après 23
ans payent moins cher mais je vais
regarder la tv en prime trois ans
mais mais vous avez des la machine à
laver ou de la versenne vous programmé
bien sûr après sa chambre pour les
choquent ou inquiètent après 23 ans à
compenser
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas ça je savais pas mais ces
gens parce que la situation soutient
qu'ils changent
et que 50 cents d'économies si vous vous
mettez votre couvert j'ai l'impression
d'être un peu ma grand mère c'est normal
c'est bête mais vous mettez un couvercle
sur la casserole quand on fait bouillir
l'eau a raison eh ben vous allez faire
quatre fois moins de dépenses
d'électricité non tout simplement parce
que le chabab il ya évidemment parce que
en général et si vous réchauffer au
micro ondes ces 75 fois moins d'énergie
consommée que si vous le faites au four
donc de temps en temps on a toujours un
peu des doutes sur le mes et il vaut
mieux prendre des douches froides ça
coûte moins cher
dans les douches non les douches froides
que ça coûte moins cher les douches
froides ah bah oui ça cause ça coûte
moins cher de toute façon en général
l'eau chaude elle et elle est chauffée
par votre ballon d'un show de la nuit
bien sûr et après que vont cogner froid
ou chaud ça choque ça change puisque je
faisais ça pour faire des économies
c'est pour ça
il ya un poste qui explosent pour les
gens c'est l'électricité ou le gaz pour
le chauffage porte en moi par exemple
quand je quitte la maison j'ai un
chauffage 19 certains me disent il faut
surtout ne pas faire ça alors le
laissait pas parce que quand on allume
un peu c'est ce que c'est vrai savons
exactement alors là vous pouvez en
utiliser les les thermostats connecter
avec un téléphone ça coûte 120 euros à
peu près mais vous allez pouvoir piloter
les heures de est latent et la
température other que vous souhaitez
c'est à dire que si vous voulez avoir 17
degrés en journée quand vous n'êtes pas
là vous programmez ça pour que la
température baisse gentiment et puis
vers 16h30 17h quand vous savez que vous
allez rentrer du boulot là vous fait
repartir gentiment là la température ça
vous fait quand même faire des économies
ces histoires là parce que si vous
baisser d'un degré la température soit
on dit mettez des pulls c'est pas idiot
vous baisser d'un degré la température
chez vous vous faites 7 % d'économie
noms en pâture des
avec l'ex en euros qu'on a gagné année
les 7 % ici mais ça peut faire beaucoup
en fin d'année oui alors à chaque fois
c'est des petits bouts c'est toujours
aussi lancer des petites gouttes d'eau
mais c'est vrai que quand on est attaché
à son budget rappelez vous quand il y
avait eu tout un scandale sur les aides
au logement et 5 euros de moins
qu'avaient été décidées les jeunes âmes
et à 35 euros sert pas pour un étudiant
si vous avez 150 200 300 euros
d'économisés à la fin de l'année c'est
quand même pas négligeable ramener
chaque mois c'est parce que vous avez
des astuces aussi au niveau de la
voiture parce qu'il ya beaucoup de vent
tourner dans des voitures qui nous
regardent qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour dépenser moins aussi alors en
voiture parce que c'est avec les
licences ça devient de plus en plus cher
c'est venu moi quand je vais mettre la
carmagnole c'est bon
mais disons beaucoup plus
alors oui alors comment on fait pour la
moitié pour la voiture ça ça ça rejoint
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure que c'est
pas forcément parce qu'on est con on
achète moins cher au départ que c'est
rentable à la fin qu'en plus vous
achetez une v1 véhicules âgés il faut
savoir que la moitié de
vous avez plus de la moitié des
véhicules en france qui roule qui sont à
plus de dix ans quand même donc le
diesel l'essence c'est encore évidemment
une problématique et plus elles sont
âgés plus elle consomme donc il faut
faire comme toi dans ces cas là
il faut faire de ce qu'on appelle
l'éco-conduite y en avait un la mère qui
m'a envoyé un texto très drôle ça va te
calmer ce qu'il dit le mec
[Rires]
est donc non mais c'est vrai que parce
que j'aimerais que vous nous donner
encore quelques astuces qui a beaucoup
de gens qui nous regardent qu'ils disent
vraiment là vous avez
la voiture par exemple je sais pas mon
plein à paris d'accord je fais dans le
neuf un parce que c'est beaucoup moins
cher mais c'est très cher parce que vous
allez là-bas c'est maintenant on fait ça
a vite et je t'assure ça fait une
économie de 20 euros non non c'est vrai
alors ça c'est parce que les parce que
l'essence à apparier déjà très peu de
stations-service et
2 euros le litre dans la vie de tous les
jours donc même au supermarché question
est-ce qu'il faut faire vous avez dit
vous avez parlé des marques voilà qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour dépenser moins
et avoir autant de produits il faut en
réalité c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure un peu anticiper et prévoir ses
courses parfois lorsqu'on commande via
le drive on a l'impression que c'est
plus cher oda ça peut l'être c'est pas
toujours le cas parce qu'aujourd'hui les
stratégies commerciales ont tendance à
mettre à peu près les mêmes prix en
rayon et sur internet mais ça un mérite
c'est que ça vous oblige à faire vos
courses way est à prévoir ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure on prévoit les
menus donc on prévoit les courses avec
et donc vous avez vous éviter la
tentation parce qu'en fait le le
problème lorsque vous allez au marché ou
lorsque vous allez dans une grande
surface et vous faites tentez vous
passez vous avez l'odeur du bien sûr et
vous du carnet sépare l'egypte rendu
certaines
brûlées fou mais moi dur mémoire du
chanteur bret huawei avait c'est vrai
j'ai cru bon d'y trouver les grands
magasins est ce que c'est vrai le
supermarché est ce que c'est vrai qu'il
va pour le coup je les fais moi même est
ce que c'est vrai qu'il faut aller vers
ce qu'on ne voit pas par exemple
oui c'est oui bah oui parce que
évidemment si les promesses et il ya des
négociations commerciales entre les
marques et dans la grande distribution
c'est la tête de gondole si je peux dire
ça c'est à dire que évidemment ce qu'on
voit en premier c'est ce qui a pu être
négocié pour avoir des ristournes pour
avoir des âges des gestes commerciaux
entre les distributeurs et les grandes
marques donc évidemment que c'est comme
n'importe quelle vitrine il vaut mieux
faire voir ce qu'on a envie de vendre
juste sur tous les abonnements quand on
a plusieurs femelles analyse en fonction
des portables tous à ce qu il ya des
petites astuces parce que c'est vrai que
ça fait beaucoup d'abonnements ce fait
beaucoup d'efforts on peut négocier un
peu mais wall appelle son opérateur ah
oui il faut faire jouer la concurrence
il ya eu il ya eu effectivement une
période notamment souviens lorsque free
est arrivé sur le marché roula du coup
tous les acteurs historiques se sont mis
à trembler et vous irez appelé tout le
monde et on vous fait un geste il n'y
avait plus rien à négocier là c'est vrai
qu'en général sur ce marché là il faut
mettre en concurrence et puis surtout
puisqu'on a un téléphone m d alerte quoi
c'est tout simple on met une alerte à la
date anniversaire si on veut si on sait
qu'on veut supprimer son abonnement un
tel ou tel
marc voilà vingt quatre 24 heures avant
on mais on met une alerte sur le
téléphone pour ce faire prévenir il ya
un truc auquel il faut faire très
attention là c'est sur l'immobilier
parce que ça m'a énormément l'immobilier
évidemment car
je sentais des
supermarchés
yaourt en bas
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'à pompage de transport en
commun que je prends beaucoup ça va si
on peut faire des économies en achetant
avant les quarts ni sang aurait été
donné le prix d'achat sera ni
cancérigène est le prix artis aller
serrer la et vous le donner les km
d'écart n'existe plus
[Applaudissements]
chez loi si j'avais trouvé
soufflot l'immobilier voilà le les taux
d'intérêt pour les prêts immobiliers
sont historiquement superba sur 20 à 25
ans vous avez air entre 1 et 1,2 1,2
pour cent de près de taux c'est superbe
a mais c'est souvent la seule chose
qu'on regarde ce qu on oublie de
regarder sur ans c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'assurance emprunteur bien sûr et alors
là il ya des négociations en ce moment
notamment un texte de loi pour pouvoir
renégocier ça parce que la plupart du
temps le prêt est adossé à l'assurance
emprunteur de votre banque vous n'avez
pas le choix et si vous renégocier ça et
vous pouvez le faire au bout d'un an
vous pouvez économiser sur un prêt de
200 mille euros ce qui est à peu près la
moyenne des prêts immobiliers en france
jusqu'à entre huit et quinze mille euros
en fonction de l'âge que vous avez donc
ça veut dire 50 euros par mois c'est
dans ça vous avez des sites internet qui
sont spécialisés qui renégocie pour
voilà et là vous avez quand même
énormément d'argent récupère des devis
avec des banques en ligne souvent les
banques en ligne sont moins chers ont
fait un devis avec une banque en ligne
on vient avec le devis
salah dhibi la donner cette manière
alors c'est bibi la
wii et sur deux a pris une question pour
les voyages il ya des fait partie du
même monde le bateau de l'homme
acheter des billets d'avion par exemple
il ya évidemment s'y prendre à l'avancé
on paye moins cher mais en plus je crois
qu'il ya des horaires ou alors passer
par un vpn
alors il ya des astuces parce que selon
les pays ce qui se laisse son siège il
paraît que même si je peux avoir des
prix totalement perdant les trois là il
ya cet aspect il faut quand même moi
j'avoue je suis pas spécialiste pour
pouvoir changer de vpn mais bon chacun
son la ccc la possible c'est un routeur
hiver c'est là où on se connecte et et
le vpn s'il est situé aux états unis par
exemple on est considéré comme habitants
les etats-unis poussent à certaines
séries dans les prix du billet alors
voilà il ya un truc moi je n'ai pas
vérifié mais qui se dit c'est que le
jeudi est en général moins cher pour
acheter des billets d'avion ah oui ça
c'est ça c'est le jeu
en fait c'est ça non mais c'est quoi oui
dans le jeudi et passe à sénart ont
effectivement ça je pense que c'est par
rapport aux booking des avions et qu'il
ya des moments comme ce qu'ils appellent
le lean management c'est-à-dire la le
remplissage optimal des désagréments que
je fais moi donc le jeudi
c'est bien demain jeudi c'est bloquer
quoi m'acheter
la raison des nombreux diplômés de
vacances club de vacances tous les clubs
de vacances où on va enfin voir des
vacances le jeudi vous réservez le jeudi
pour votre beau ce week-end en vacances
c'est toujours moins cher de jeudi c'est
vrai ou pas qu'en bien c'est à dire il
avait dit tout haut on dit
tu nous fais chier excusez moi je
connais jeudi de sauveur il n'est pas
scellé par session est venu je peux dire
qu'il est pas parce que
je peux te dire plus avant avant qu'on
fasse au point de campagne avec vous de
rester alors et bien sûr la petite
astuce si on reste sur sur les voyages
il faut aussi faire attention
parce que il ya des traceurs ah oui
c'est à dire que vous l'avez sûrement
remarqué vous regardez les tiens j'irais
bien rome tel week-end vous avez un prix
qui s'affiche et puis on vous dit vous
reste trois places dans l'avion et puis
vous y retournez le lendemain pour
boucler le truc le billet d'avion n'est
plus au même prix les plus chers ah
ouais mais si votre femme ou votre mari
fait avec un autre ordinateur votre
adresse ip le même truc vous allez
retrouver le prix de départ lorsqu'il
faut oui mais c'est comme ça sur easyjet
parti donc et c'est vrai aussi pour le
train donc il faut faire attention
on est on est un tout petit peu
d'humains vivant sur l'épreuve
sur les chronos c'est hallucinant tu
fais une propage
sur mycologie à vérifier j'ai de mon
ordinateur je regardais je regarde deux
jours après du même ordinateur
effectivement comme il sait que c'est
moi qui étais en train de chercher c'est
hallucinant pas illégal ça sur les
trappes parce que sur les 360 parce que
vous avez vous avez vous avez validé le
fait d'avoir des cookies notamment oui
j'accepte ça et ça incroyable
franchement c'est fort vous êtes mariés
oui elle met votre femme elle peut pas
faire un écart et
les aubergines
eh
ben tu feras tu as moussaka en mars
ashton non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
les bras des coûts non mais sa femme le
comtal robert des courses avec
les staffs et sur les shipstern non mais
c'est vrai c'est qu'il faut acheter des
produits de saison oui
vous allez acheter plutôt les mois je
fais des melons ce mot
doit venir de loin ils viennent de loin
et de carbone puis c'est vrai mais oui
la pastèque jamais
non plus été mangé quoi comme fouille
alors
tin tin tin avait pas d autrui malgré
cette façon vous si bon jeu des
pastèques et les melons
et pastèques et bénévoles ont aidé par
les voilà à leur lit